there are 17 million people in the LA
area there's enough people for every
trainer I know you guys all want to
become trainers there's enough people
there there are enough people for you
the key is can I do right with the
people I'm working with can I give them
a hundred percent in my workout every
single time okay so if you won't tell
you right now you type in top celebrity
trainer my name's gonna come off the guy
sitting next to his name is Gunnar
Peterson who let me just kind of say
list of some of the people you trained
Brady kardashians Stallone Aflac let me
do it Ben F Lee you got a list of them
there you go I'm in the right zip code
look where I am I have great parking I'm
in the right zip code I'm centrally
located if you're in Brentwood or West
Hollywood or downtown you're probably
cruising through this part of town or
else you live here and she said she said
just park in our building and Mario's
like that I think he said over that's a
no-no in Beverly Hills to have parking
in the building seven is not exactly and
you're in a prime prime location yep
so anyways and on top of that by the way
the Lakers just hired him as the head
strength coach we got that you're proud
of me or what up strength goes excellent
work and so how does a guy like you go
from being who you are we're pretty much
your entire family's gonna do how do you
go from there to not be able to work
today I didn't change I stayed I mean in
terms of Who I am I know I am because my
family will work tight I would never
have attitude or you go about any of
that and when the job came up I didn't
have to I'm able to work it where I can
still do what I need to do with my own
facility as well as do the work of the
Lakers so I split my days I get here at
4:30 4:45 sometimes and I'm here till 8
then I go down to the Lakers and I'm
there till 1:00 and then I'm back here
till 6:00 that I'm home it's in growver
train Kobe any train MJ you know and
Wade he was MJ for 15 years so he was
mainly LA he also ran hoops the gym so
he did this straddle that I did and I've
tell a number of trainers who want to
jump who want to cross that fence I said
look if I if I can do it anybody can do
it but just know that it's two different
jobs and I'm talking about training
and gym owner that's two very different
jobs you could be a phenomenal trainer
and fail miserably as a gym owner
whereas you can be a terrific gym owner
but when it comes to training people you
bomb in all the world in the business
world level to being somebody that's
great in sales or maybe being a seal yes
a good company yeah I think they just
because you're great it still is right
and running somebody can run the numbers
and tell you what you need to bump up
with your business but if you put them
face to face with a customer you lose
all your business so yeah this one the
questions I ask them I want to ask you
as well I'm sure you know what you're
gonna say for you I mean literally
Kendall general just walked out you just
got done with her and so you got
everybody comes here these are people
that are you know 98 million followers
on Instagram everyone knows me paparazzi
I have money
I know paparazzi in here not in here
paparazzi proof I got the eight that's
right you save them with that but they
have a lot of attention well yeah how do
you get me to push me to continue on and
to develop my body to the next level how
does that relationship work out and
they're a real tough conversation that
they explain at some point it's not it's
not about berating you or embarrassing
you or shaming you were insulting you I
don't need to do that I don't sell
Fitness anybody I don't push fitness I
don't go out and put you know flyers or
my business card under people's
windshield wipers at the mall I'm the
people are coming because it's something
they want by the time they get here the
motivations already kicked in they're
self-motivated these are people who if
you look at their careers they're
self-motivated nobody has to nudge those
people and go a time to get up gotta go
to work today they're up there out there
they've probably done more before work
than most people do at work your
clientele these are pros these are
people that really really want to do
high achieving high for a little one
percent correct and I leave my purse and
I love those people that's great and
they may not even know they fire me up
they're fired up so they want to work
out they're fired up to train with
somebody who's passionate about the
training but I'm fired up because of who
they are and the fact that they've found
a way to actively prioritize this and
fit this into their already jam-packed
day I love people like this don't tell
me I don't have time but the people that
I want
this go back to you when you were just
getting started you're somebody but
you're not yet maybe at this level when
you first started with names was it
automatically a list names you were
training from day one or no I mean to me
that's funny when they were listing us a
list B list to me everybody comes here
as an a-lister whether it's an attorney
whether it's a doctor it's just a guy
who inherited money and he's just
enjoying his life but he wants to stay
in shape you treat everybody like
they're an a-lister I don't know you
know it's like somebody said to me once
you have to charge celebrities
differently and I think that's I think
that's wrong I think that's I think
that's wrong you can't if I ran a
restaurant and I say hey you want the
steak it's 26 dollars I'll wait a minute
wait you're on a TV show the steaks 42
dollars you can't do that no you can't
do that so yeah and if you're providing
a service you're charging for your time
just like that's very common in your
world I find it wrong it's great for
other people it's not my way so what's
been the biggest evolution from you know
Gunnar Peterson 1.0 2.0 3.0 to today so
I started in home going to people's
homes what I was driving all over the
place and you can't obviously maximize
your time and and the workouts aren't as
effective even if the person has a gym
it's not gonna be as dialed as the gym I
put together this is what level how long
were you two years in home eight years
in a gym and then I started my own gym
and I did nine years there 17 18 19 yet
when I've been here 10 years I was
killing over there hours wives just back
to back to back anywhere from 48 50 to
65 one-on-one hours a week plus spinning
classes as much as I could do I took all
comers whatever let's go I was tireless
you know and then you get married you
have kids and your priorities have to or
should shift in my opinion and you dial
it back and I see seven eight nine
people a day I do a lot of prep I print
out workouts for every single person
every single day I do the prep the night
before I sit with my kids whichever kid
is doing the most homework I'll probably
sit with that kid and I'll do my
homework while they do their homework
and I try to infuse a little bit of
levity in the workout
I'm not in LA I can't afford you I am in
LA but I can't afford you I'm in Austin
I'm in Miami I'm in Chicago I'm in a
city how do I know how to hire an
interview trainer to say this is who
will be my trainer so I would go through
one of the governing bodies and they
have you know they have a like it's
mapped out where their members are so
the national strength and conditioning
Association NASM ACSM ace and you can
reach out to them I'm sure you can do it
on website and just say I'm looking for
a trainer in this area but after that
it's not unlike dating in that you may
have to kiss a couple frogs you know
you're gonna have to test drive because
it might be a great person that has a
ton of knowledge and is really qualified
at communicating the knowledge but then
you speak to him and you're like I don't
like this guy this guy's a Democrat this
guy's a Republican this guy's you know
religion that I'm not gonna like and
that all plays into it was in yeah you
just don't like he looks like he looks
like my uncle it was always rude to me I
don't want to train them I mean whatever
there's you know there's things that you
you go I can work with this guy you feel
it right away okay so let's just say I
find a guy that I connect get along yep
after that how do I know that this guy
knows what he's know this girl knows
what she's doing
so I think you have to trust the
certification process I would couch that
with just because you're certified
doesn't mean you're good at just because
you're not certified doesn't mean you're
not good so to me a certification means
the person bothered learning X amount of
knowledge and regurgitating it on test
day are they always looking for new
things not new
you know bells and whistles kind of
stuff I'm into that because I like stuff
I think it's fun I think it's fun to to
trick the mind to stay engaged to feel
it slightly differently on a shoulder
press that's here versus here versus
here
that's my thing you don't need all that
you could do this if you're a qualified
trainer with you know two cinder blocks
and a broomstick but if I'm not in LA
I gotta find a way to go look for
someone back in the days
magazines I still look at all the health
and fitness manager said Muscle &
Fitness I think you go for like 10 years
men have many more yeah yeah 10 years
you got flex you got my other nails I
mean there was a magazine that was my
favorite one by Bill Phillips it was
called muscle media to death I know if
you mil sure sure of course it was
something about muscle media that was
scientific and formula and all this
stuff that they would give what source
do you trust you I'll read everything
from T nation bodybuilding.com muscular
development muscle fitness flex and then
go the other up shape Muslim fitness
hers allure any of those they're gonna
be there's gonna be a fitness tip or a
health tip and if I can find a way to
bring that in and weave it into a way to
communicate what I want to get to my
people then I'll use it it's a business
of poaching right I'll take from
powerlifting I'll take from distance
running I'll take from yoga I'll take
from Pilates I'll take from what it from
bodybuilding
there are a million sources at some
point you have enough knowledge enough
empirical data that you are able to
distill it down to what actually you
know works so you're still not leaning
towards one source like for instance in
the business world somebody may ask me
magazine entrepreneur you know fortune
Forbes Wall Street I may say I'll lean
towards Forbes first and I'll lean this
you're not saying anybody that's the
leading indicator today I'm not saying
the leaders not out there I'm sure they
are I'm saying I treat them all as
whatever I see I read it wouldn't make
sense a sure change also social media I
mean you can't deny what you see it
comes across on Instagram there's a
there are so many constant student you
Constance Kasich yeah but I'm also a lot
weirdly Intuit and passionate about and
I look at it and and I'll send it to the
guy I train with Brad Siskin and I'll
say hey we should try this tomorrow or
let's look at this I'll senators and
Caylee who works me I'll say let's pick
up one of those pieces of equipment you
think that's one of the reasons cuz you
said
I've been able to outlast these guys you
know I've been around and I've done this
and I've done that you think a big part
of it is maybe the fact that obviously
the work ethic is in place but because
you're constantly wanting to learn him
the minute you think you've got it it's
on live or not this is this is an
evolving field and it's constantly
evolving and as we learn more about what
the body responds to it and stressors
that affect you know you may be doing
something outside of you may be doing
something a work that is so detrimental
to your health that it's negating X
percent of what your body is doing the
gym it could be you're feeding whether
it's your food it's your quantity or
quality or your timing of your food
right of calories not a calorie is not a
calorie if you wrote a 2,500 calorie
diet a day for example and you eat 2,500
calories at 6 a.m.
nothing till the next exam that's going
to affect you differently than if you go
500 500 500 or if you go all day nothing
25 before sleep so playing with it you
have to be open to that and you're gonna
read different studies some of them are
crazy and you go come on dude
no way there's some very weird work
hours that's something I can I said I'm
like this guy says he swears by this I
don't eat till 6 o'clock at night what I
do is I try that I'll try it for two
days three days for it whatever it is
you know I'll try the Master Cleanse you
know okay I'll give it a shot
cayenne pepper great B agave honey
whatever it was and lemon juice oh I'm
trying that after like two days and we
oh my god hard to focus but that's just
my experience with it so I'll have
somebody coming in and say have you ever
tried that and I'll say I did and here's
what I got out of it but again focus
group of one I'm one dude I did it for
two days
III burn you know I run this hot during
a day from this time in the morning
through this time of night didn't give
me enough energy it couldn't do it yeah
we tried to ketogenic diet sure half did
I like it it was interesting I don't
think it's for everybody do I think it's
effective and dropping weight before you
know fill in the blank goal whether it's
prom or class reunion or beach vacation
yeah you could make it work how true are
you gonna be to it someone sees you and
says and
love to have the Kardashians as an
account the the biggest following family
social media in the world some America
has less people living here than that
entire family combined on following on
Instagram right okay how do I go to the
point where one day I have all these
successful people that want to be
trained by you so how do I get these
people that wanted me to be their you
know realtor agent whoever maybe how do
I get to that point you have to know who
you are who are you are you are you
fast-talking Flip vulgar or you straight
down the middle not racy with your
language stick to the facts just the
facts that guy I mean who are you
and who does that appeal to so I haven't
sold this conversation with a trainer
yesterday and he was saying a similar
thing right but he wasn't real estate he
was a trainer and he said I want to do
that I want to do that I wanna I said
what demographic are you trying to train
because he had something a program that
had something sexy in it and I said
what's the demographic said ah I just
want to get all that over like the cool
Hollywood people of them I think to me I
think that word is a red flag I think
anything with sexy abs sexy glutes sexy
looks sexy body I think is objectifying
I think it's it's not something that
people take seriously because it's sort
of intent what's sexy what's sexy to you
may not be sexy to me and I don't know
some people may not even feel like they
are sexy or will ever be or even have
permission to be sexy so that's not what
they're really going for I think I think
you're narrowing that down so I wouldn't
use that word and if and if you're not
particularly sexy I certainly wouldn't
use that word so you got to know who you
are and who you're targeting are you
targeting do you think the guys these
think the business men in Beverly Hills
we're gonna go work out and do this
hardcore athletic workout if I call it
sexy athlete workout I don't think so I
think that turns people off right out of
the gate so you have to know who you are
who you're speaking to how you're
approaching them
is your ru e-blast guy or you Tex guy I
do all my own texting and scheduling
with everybody I do it with the head
coach and the athletic trainer of the
Lakers I do it here with every single
celebrity every single athlete I text
them myself cuz I'm that guy
was it was there ever a breakthrough
when you got into this market like did
you have a breakthrough moment because
you're saying you were going to people's
homes right I moved the dorms I'm going
to training then you work out of a gym
for eight years and then nine years so
was there oh you know in terms of the
people I'm training first climb wasn't a
no nice to get into that market yeah my
first clients were all I mean people who
definitely had disposable income to pay
a trainer for sure we they're not a lot
of people who are strapped for money
that are reaching out to a trainer I
would think you know they're if they're
really strapped they're looking at more
basic cost than a trainer so the people
that are looking for that already have
the disposable income for it right and
then you get the people who want to
spend whatever it takes because they
want to speed up the process and as a
trainer you can't speed the process in
terms of what the body is doing
especially if they're not doing the
right things outside you know if you're
in the gym with me three four five six
days a week that's three four five six
hours a week that leaves you at the
least a hundred and sixty two hours on
your own what you do with that did you
make the right choices food did you make
the right choices with recovery did you
make the right choices
with hydration did you try to reduce the
stressors that are causing your body to
to go into that state where you you know
everything is breaking down that's just
hard to do you know you got to be doing
that outside of here
got it and so okay so then the next
question for you obviously you're not I
don't I don't assume your rate is gonna
be the same as the rate at a person at
24-hour fitness at a person at Equinox I
mean if I'm tricking
- come - you're not here to hide not
unless a propeller somebody's sponsoring
they're not for you so if that's the
case in your numbers gonna increase you
have to create ancillary revenue streams
okay for me the freemium but that's also
why I can't pitch what I do to trainers
around the world hey start a gym like
this and in this part of town and do
this and don't worry if you go broke I
can't that's not a great pitch right so
if you're trying to do it this way here
and and really I could do this here if I
had four more trainers who worked my
hours here yeah right yeah I could make
that work but I keep it with two of us
because I want their experience I want
this to be a safe environment I want
this to be where the person doesn't feel
like they're you know somebody's in the
corner taking a cell phone picture of
them that nobody needs that so this is
not a membership deal at all there is no
membership notice I'm sure there's no
it's I'm with somebody and my other
trainers with somebody that's it they're
never more than four people upstairs
we're 5,000 square feet they're never
more than four people here ever so what
you do is you so the way it worked out
was I create an ancillary revenue stream
or answer owners streams right so you do
that with things online with corporate
alliances with you know works supposed
to be gideon and merchandising sales i'm
leaving that to my wife that's not why
you don't want to see what i think so
those are ways to offset it so then the
lesson there would be fun watching this
is while I'm doing this I gotta find
ancillary ways to if you want to do it
like this if you want to do with this
model yeah if you want to do this model
in this location like I'm very you know
geo-specific
this is nine oh two one oh right you
could do this model in another city
maybe doesn't work maybe but you could
definitely do it in another city where
your overhead is a little bit less add
two trainers drop my overhead by twenty
percent which is what you would get real
estate marketing don't know
and it would work yeah so you could you
could essentially take this as a you
can't just chart you can't just gouge
the client and charge them more you lose
them if the client if the client is
paying you what they're paying their
legal team they're not they're not
they're not gonna stay it happened to me
and the guy did it to me and I wouldn't
ask the guy that referred to me says
well they find that at Google you have
much money over your net worth this you
W so I came all the Guyana so why are
you charging me he said what I mean I
said that I paid this much why are you
asking me for this much we talked about
that earlier you lost me instantly
bother which are you right not only that
but I'm sure if anybody wherever that is
since you hey I've got this trainer I'm
going to see you go pump the brake right
yeah so he so he you know he burned that
that's that's scorched earth now 100%
okay so my takeaway from you is I'm
always gonna be straightforward I'm
always gonna be fair about it I'm always
gonna be forthright I'm always gonna
text you directly and we're gonna work
when you're here now we may you said
we're left we may [ __ ] around during the
workout what you're working out we make
goof we may joke there may be you know
whatever banter there is but you're
working out gunner in the family who
grew up in everybody want to do yeah not
everybody but the most people want to do
mother father brother all what to do
what's how we do it so what was this
standard of expectation from parents was
it a high expectation type of family
yeah was it a competitive environment or
another my mother and my brother are
freakishly competitive and it's and it's
funny I don't care and people say well
if you don't show me a good loser and
I'll show you a real loser I'm a good
loser I don't think I'm a loser I don't
if we play ping pong you win I don't
care I'm competitive against me okay
beat your prior best constant what can I
do
always it's that it's that other we
long-term that wins
let's hope it's that quote about golf
right
yeah I'm not competing against the other
golfers I'm competing against the course
in my prior best score that's right so
that's how I am with this I'm not
competing against another trainer all
the guys that are out there
by the way there's 17 million people in
the LA area
there's enough people for every trainer
and you guys all want to become trainers
there's enough people there there are
enough people for you the key is can I
do right with the people I'm working
with can I give them a hundred percent
in my workout every single time and I
can tell you that's when I stopped
seeing 13 14 people a day and I pulled
it back to 10 11 12 because I couldn't
deliver at the level that I wanted to I
didn't have anybody complain it's your
schedule like on a daily bit like what
time you start I get up at 3:45 I'm here
for 30 I do my own work out till 6:00
cleanup start people 6 37 36 37 and
finish and get out are typical sessions
one hour yeah
ok I have some I have a guy's on has a
number of TV shows and sometimes I see
him for 35 5:30 and then I go work yet
to it yeah and then I find a way to jam
mine in somewhere so let me ask you
would you be open if I come back to LA
and we find a time that's good for both
of us and we do a routine I am motivated
so you're not getting some other it's
not self-motivated and we do routine and
we record that with you and you show it
to but one work that's gonna look like
with okay the answer is yes but in terms
of showing them what it's gonna look
like you're not gonna show them what
it's gonna look because you're gonna
show them what that work at is remember
I write a different workout for every
person every day because just on a
physiological level you're changing
you're changing right now right the you
right now is gonna be different if you
get eight hours sleep or if you get
three hours sleep and what you look like
at 8:00 tomorrow morning right so they
may see they'll see that workout I'm
fine with that but if they came back and
saw the next workout it'd be a totally
different workout I don't repeat the
movements that much you need a long-term
commitment
[Music]
yeah yeah it's a lot of time commitment
well there's a reason why you are who
you are
Lakers we've had magic before we had a
mat or event we have James blocks that's
my boss how is that we're representing
the brand you're excited about this
whole you know where it's headed towards
on what's happening your clientele is
gonna change in twelve months half of it
how can you not be excited about
representing that brand ripple next year
we'll see it'll be interesting there's
no wax contract we could give up it
should be very interesting yeah I mix
that I don't think I'm one of those well
that's not how I see that plan out
really important role anyways
brother this has been a blast thank you
thanks for allowing us to come to your
beautiful gym here with this unique
equipment that you have you with Captain
America you should be you should
actually do some b-roll upstairs so
people don't think about this you don't
think this is this is the downstairs
part this is not the old you cannot
believe it's only two trainers that is
so amazing to me he's over there right
now here and it's so amazing - it's cool
brother thank you